♪ ♪
STAY ON LET’S GET THE LATEST ON
VACCINE, THERAPIES AND THE REST
OF THE DEVELOPMENTS.
JOINING US, WHITE HOUSE RESPONSE
CHLORINATOR DR. DEBORAH BIRX.
WE HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS, A
LOT FROM VIEWERS.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE AFRAID.
THEY ARE UNCERTAIN.
THEY ARE FACING A SCHOOL YEAR,
MANY PARENTS WONDERING WHAT’S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
TONIGHT WHERE IS THIS VIRUS IN
YOUR MIND?
WE JUST HEARD THE PRESIDENT BUT
FROM YOU, THE MEDICAL EXPERT,
WHERE IS IT?
>> THIS PARTICULAR PANDEMIC WE
ARE EXPERIENCING ACROSS THE
SOUTH, SOUTHEAST AND INTO THE
SOUTHWEST AND WEST IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE
EXPERIENCED IN MARCH AND APRIL.
WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT?
THIS EPIDEMIC ALL APPEARED
ACROSS THE SOUTH AND THE WEST
AFTER JUNE 10TH, SIMULTANEOUSLY
PREVIOUSLY IN THE MARCH-APRIL
TIME FRAME, FIRST WE HAD THE
NEW YORK METRO FOLLOWING
WASHINGTON STATE AND THEN A
SERIES OF METROS THAT WENT DOWN
IN A PERIOD OF TIME, OFTEN TWO
OR THREE WEEKS APART.
THIS TIME WE SAW WIDE VIRUS
SPREAD ACROSS COUNTIES, ACROSS
RURAL AREAS, CROSS MALL METROS
AND BIG METROS ALL THE WAY
ACROSS THE SOUTH, SOUTHWEST AND
WEST, ALMOST SIMULTANEOUSLY.
THIS WAS AN EVENT THAT WE SEE
CAN BE TRACED TO MEMORIAL DAY
AND OPENING UP AND PEOPLE
TRAVELING AGAIN AND BEING ON
VACATION.
WE ARE TRACKING IT BECAUSE WHERE
IT HASN’T HAPPENED YET IS OUR
MIDWEST AND OUR NORTHEAST THAT
WAS SO HARD HIT IN MARCH AND
APRIL.
IN SO WE ARE WATCHING VERY
CAREFULLY.
>> Bret: WHAT IS THE TOP STAT
YOU ARE FOLLOWING, WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT DATA DAY, THE TOP
STATISTIC?
>> WE HAVE A REPORT ON EVERY
MONDAY TO GOVERNORS, IT’S ABOUT
TEN PAGES PER STATE AND IT GOES
INTO DETAIL.
WHAT WE THINK IS THE MOST
SENSITIVE INDICATOR IS WHAT WE
CALL TEST POSITIVITY.
IT ONLY HAS TO GO UP A TINY BIT.
LET’S SAY YOU HAVE 3% TEST
POSITIVE AND THEN THE NEXT WEEK
YOU HAD 3.3%.
IT’S WHEN TO START WATCHING IT.
WE THINK THAT’S THE EARLIEST
INDICATOR.
THAT’S WHY WE SHOW IT AT COUNTY
LEVELS, METRO LEVELS, SMALL
CITIES AND LARGE METRO AREAS AS
WELL AS THE STATE LEVEL SO EVERY
GOVERNOR AND EVERY MAYOR ON
EVERY HEALTH COMMISSIONER CAN
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IN THEIR STATE.
SO WE CAN REALLY PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE STATES ON
HOW BEST TO CONTROL THIS VIRUS.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT
MENTIONED.
OVER 50,343,000 TESTS.
POSITIVE TESTS, 4,653,000.
THE POSITIVE PERCENT IS 9%.
HERE’S THE QUESTION WE ARE
GETTING A LOT AND THAT IS THE
TIME IT TAKES TO GET THE TEST
AND THE RESULTS FROM THE TEST.
IF IT TAKES ONE, TWO, THREE,
EVEN FOR DAYS, WHAT’S THE
PURPOSE OF THE TEST FROM A
MEDICAL CONTACT TRACING
POSSIBILITY?
>> YOUR RIGHTS, THE TURNAROUND
TIMES PARTICULARLY ACROSS THE
SOUTH ARE TOO LONG.
WE’VE BEEN WORKING AT STATE
LEVELS, WHEN THE PRESIDENT
TALKED ABOUT A CHANGE IN
STRATEGY, INCREASING OUR
STRATEGY.
HAVING A TESTING STRATEGY BUT TO
ADDRESS THE TURNAROUND TIMES.
IT WILL BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
THE MOST HARDEST HIT STATES,
THEY ARE HAVING THE LONGEST TURN
AROUND TIMES.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
IF YOU LOOK RIGHT NOW AND YOU
HAD IT ON JUST BEFORE, WE HAVE
THREE STATES THAT ARE EQUIVALENT
TO WHAT THE WORST CONDITIONS
WERE AS FAR AS NUMBER OF TESTS
REQUIRED, NEW YORK.
WE HAVE THREE STATES APPROACHING
THOSE CASE NUMBERS AND NOW WE
NEED THREE TIMES THE NUMBER OF
TESTS THAT WE HAD BEFORE.
SO WE ARE REALLY WORKING TO
INCREASE POOLING.
WE KNOW IT CAN DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE THROUGHPUT.
WE NEED THE NORTHEAST AND
MIDWEST THAT HAVE LOW TEST
POSITIVE RATES TO MOVE TO
POOLING SO THOSE TESTS CAN BE
MOVED TO THE SOUTH AND THE
SOUTHWEST AND WEST JUST LIKE
EARLY ON WE SHIFTED A LOT OF
TESTING TO THE NORTHEAST.
WE NEED THE NORTHEAST NOW TO
HELP US BY DOING POOLING.
THEY HAVE TEST POSITIVITY’S
UNDER 3% OFTEN.
WE THINK THEY ARE IN A PERFECT
SITUATION TO COMBINE THREE OR
FOUR DIFFERENT TESTS IN ONE TUBE
TO RUN IT AND IT INCREASES OUR
CAPACITY BY FOUR TIMES.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE ASKING THE
STATES TO WORK ON.
TO LOOK AT POOLING IN THE
MIDWEST AND THE NORTHEAST SO WE
CAN MAKE MORE TESTS AVAILABLE TO
THE SOUTH AND SOUTHWEST.
>> Bret: IS IT FAIR TO SAY
THAT THAT’S NATIONAL FAILURE,
TESTING?
BACK IN MARCH 13TH, HERE’S WHAT
WE WERE SAYING BACK THEN.
YOU WERE SAYING IN THE
BRIEFINGS.
>> SCIENCE AND PATIENTS AND
PEOPLE OF INTEREST CAN GO AND
FILL OUT A SCREENING
QUESTIONNAIRE.
THEY WOULD MOVE DOWN THIS TO BE
TOLD WHERE THE DRIVE-THRU
OPTIONS WOULD BE FOR THEM TO
RECEIVE THIS TEST.
LABS WILL MOVE TO THE HIGH
THROUGHPUT AUTOMATED MACHINES TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE RESULTS IN 24
TO 36 HOURS.
>> Bret: THAT JUST DID NOT
MATERIALIZE.
HOW COME?
IT DIDN’T MATERIALIZE ALL
THROUGH MAY AND THE FIRST PART
OF JUNE AND ALMOST TO THE
END OF JUNE.
WE HAD TURN AROUND TIMES IN LESS
THAN 24 HOURS, 48 HOURS WHEN YOU
INCLUDE THE FACT THAT WE HAD TO
SHIP THE SAMPLES.
THE DRIVE-THRU’S WERE WORKING.
THE PHARMACIES AND WE HAD
MULTIPLE SITES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAD POINT-OF-CARE AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS LEVEL OF
OUTBREAK AND THAT’S WHY I WANTED
TO START THAT WAY, WE HAVE
ALMOST 70% OF EVERY PARISH IN
LOUISIANA WITH A TEST POSITIVITY
ABOVE 10%.
WE HAVE ALMOST 65% OF ALL THE
COUNTIES IN ALABAMA AND
MISSISSIPPI.
I WAS JUST IN THE FIELD AT ALL
OF THESE NINE STATES WITH THESE
RECENT OUTBREAKS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY’RE FACING.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT
EPIDEMIC THAN WE HAD IN MARCH
AND APRIL.
IT WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL TESTS
TESTS.
THIS SEARCH AND THIS DEGREE OF
CASES, SO WIDESPREAD COMPARED TO
PREVIOUSLY, IT DOES HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY
INCREASING OUR TESTS AND HAVING
A STRATEGY THAT SURGES TESTS IN
THE AREA SO WE CAN DECREASE THE
TURNAROUND TIMES.
WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THOSE ARE
WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYBODY TO KNOW IMMEDIATELY
WHETHER THEY ARE POSITIVE OR NOT
SO THEY CAN BE ISOLATED AND
PREVENT FURTHER TRANSMISSION.
>> Bret: WE HAVE TWEETS AND
FACEBOOK POSTS FROM VIEWERS.
IF YOU HAVE A COUPLE MORE
♪ ♪
’S THE ONE WE ARE BACK WITH
DR. DEBORAH BIRX ABOUT THE
LATEST ON THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE PRESIDENT JUST SAID, HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT SCHOOLS REOPENING
AND ABOUT KIDS AND INFECTION
RATES AND HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> CHILDREN WHO GO TO SCHOOL AND
GO BACK HOME, SOME LIVE WITH
THEIR GRANDPARENTS.
THERE IS A REAL RISK.
WOULD YOU UNDERSTAND --
>> President Trump: THEY DO
SAY THEY DON’T TRANSMIT VERY
EASILY AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THAT THEY DON’T TRANSMIT
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT IT AND
STUDYING IT VERY HARD THAT
PARTICULAR SUBJECT.
THAT THEY DON’T BRING IT HOME
WITH THEM.
THEY DON’T CATCH IT EASILY.
THEY DON’T BRING IT HOME EASILY
AND IF THEY DO CATCH IT, THEY
GET BETTER FAST.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT FACTOR.
WHERE LOOKING AT IT STRONGLY.
WILL BE REPORTING ABOUT A.
>> Bret: IS THAT RIGHT?
IS THAT WHAT YOU’RE LOOKING AT
THEM WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT KIDS
AND TRANSMITTING?
>> IT’S A REAL KEY QUESTION.
THE BEST STUDY OUT SO FAR IS A
STUDY FROM SOUTH KOREA THAT
LOOKED AT CHILDREN UNDER TEN AND
OVER TEN AND I THINK WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND WHAT WE ARE
REALLY TRYING TO DO RIGHT NOW IS
TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT THE
ANTIBODY LEVELS ARE ALREADY IN
CHILDREN UNDER 18 SO WE ARE
LAUNCHING A VERY LARGE SURVEY
ACROSS ALL AGE GROUPS TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE HAS THIS VIRUS
BEN, WHO HAS BEEN INFECTED, WHO
IS IN FACTABLE AND WHO IS
TRANSMITTING THE VIRUS?
THERE’S OPEN QUESTIONS AND
THAT’S WHY THE PRESIDENT
CONCLUDED WITH WE ARE STARTING
IT HARD.
IT’S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
DO CHILDREN UNDER TEN TRANSMIT
THE VIRUS LESS?
THAT’S WHAT THE SOUTH KOREA
STUDY SUGGESTED BUT I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE CONFIRMED HERE.
I THINK THAT’S THE KIND OF
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE TO BE
CRITICALLY ANSWERED AND I THINK
THE MULTIGENERATIONAL HOUSEHOLD
QUESTION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
I COME FROM ONE OF THOSE
MULTIGENERATIONAL HOUSEHOLDS.
I HAVE A 96-YEAR-OLD ANNA
91-YEAR-OLD MOTHER AND FATHER
THAT I AM ALWAYS ABOUT.
I DON’T SEE THEM.
I UNDERSTAND.
>> Bret: PARENTS WANT KIDS TO
BE IN SCHOOL BUT THIS IS A
CRUCIAL QUESTION.
WHERE ALMOST COMING TO AUGUST
AND SCHOOLS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT THEY’RE GOING TO DO.
THIS SEEMS TO BE KIND OF A
LINCHPIN AS TO WHETHER THEY’RE
GOING TO OPEN OR DO DISTANCE
LEARNING.
WHAT’S YOUR RECOMMENDATION?
>> THERE’S THREE PIECES AND I
THINK THE CDC HAS PUT THIS OUT
WELL AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT
WILL TALK ABOUT SCHOOLS AGAIN
THIS WEEK AND THE CDC WILL PUT
OUT ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT’S A VERY IMPORTANT POINT.
CHILDREN THAT HAVE PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS THAT WE KNOW ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE VIRUS, THEY
PROBABLY SHOULD NOT BE IN AND IN
SCHOOL SITUATION WITH HIS ACTIVE
VIRUS CIRCULATING.
TEACHERS THAT HAVE WHAT WE CALL
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS THAT PUT
THEM AT A HIGHER RISK FOR MORE
SEVERE DISEASE, THEY HAVE TO BE
ACCOMMODATED.
THE MAJORITY OF THE CHILDREN,
ONCE THERE RISK?
WE KNOW FROM DATA THAT CHILDREN
DO QUITE WELL WITH THE VIRUS.
IF WE PROTECT TEACHERS, WE HAVE
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM BUT
ARE PROTECTED THROUGH
INNOVATIONS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE PUTTING UP
PLASTIC SHIELDS.
MANY SCHOOLS ARE HAVING CHILDREN
AND TEACHERS AND MASKS.
WE KNOW THESE THINGS WORK AND I
THINK IT REALLY REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PLAN AND BE
FLEXIBLE AND PUT THE CHILD AT
THE CENTER TO DECIDE WHAT’S
BETTER FOR THE CHILDREN OF
AMERICA AND WHAT’S BEST TO
PROTECT THE CHILDREN AND THEIR
HOUSEHOLD?
EVERYBODY’S GOING TO HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH IT.
>> Bret: A COUPLE VIEWER
QUESTIONS.
THESE ARE RELATED.
"WE ARE HEARING REPORTS
ANTIBODIES ARE NOT LASTING LONG
POST INFECTION.
HOW DOES IT CHANGE THE GAME FOR
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT?"
SAME QUESTION, "IF YOU TESTED
POSITIVE WHETHER FULL ON
SYMPTOMS OR ASYMPTOMATIC, CAN
YOU BE REINFECTED?"
DO WE KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION?
>> GREAT IMMUNOLOGIC QUESTIONS
AND I TRAINED IN CLINICAL
IMMUNOLOGY.
IT’S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THE FIRST QUESTION ABOUT
PERSISTENCE OF ANTIBODIES.
EVEN WHEN WE ARE VACCINATED, OUR
ANTI-BEAUTIESANTIBODIES WAYNE
WHEN YOU ENCOUNTER THE VIRUS,
THE ANTIBODIES AND IMMUNE
RESPONSE IMMEDIATELY SURGES.
WHAT MAY BE TAKES YOU 14 DAYS TO
DEVELOP APPEARS IN FOR 24 TO 48
HOURS AND ALLOWS YOU TO CLEAR
THE VIRUS.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS WITH OTHER
VIRUSES AND OTHER INFECTIOUS
DISEASES.
THE QUESTION ABOUT CAN YOU BE
REINFECTED, WE HAVE A LOT OF
CASES OUT THERE AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF CASES OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS.
WE DON’T SEE THIS HIGH LEVEL OF
REINFECTION.
WHAT ASSURES ME IS WE KNOW THAT
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD, ONCE THEY ARE
INFECTED, THEY MOUNT AN IMMUNE
RESPONSE, THE ANTIBODY RESPONSE
AND THE CELLULAR RESPONSE AND
THEY CLEAR THE VIRUS.
THAT’S THE ROAD MAP FOR VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT’S THE ROAD MAP FOR
ANTIBODIES FOR THERAPEUTIC SIN
THAT’S WHAT’S SO ENCOURAGING
ABOUT THIS VIRUS AND OUR ABILITY
TO CLEAR IT.
>> Bret: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HAD A MASSIVE PIECE IN WHICH
THEY HAVE THIS SENTENCE.
"INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE DR. BIRX
WAS THE CHIEF EVANGELIST FOR THE
IDEA THAT THE THREAT FROM THE
VIRUS WAS FADING."
DID YOU READ IT AND WHAT DID YOU
MAKE OF IT?
>> I AM A DATA PERSON.
I WENT BACK TO THAT VERY
SPECIFIC DAY.
I REPORT OUT THE DATA EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO I WENT BACK TO
THAT DAY AND A LOOK TO MY
REPORT.
MY REPORT STARTED OUT WITH "WE
ARE SEEING IMPROVEMENTS IN
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY BUT WE
ARE SEEING INCREASING CONCERNS
AND WE ARE NOT AT PEAK IN BOSTON
OR CHICAGO.
WE HAVE NEW CONCERNS IN HOUSTON
AND WE HAVE NEW HOT SPOTS
DEVELOPING IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND ACROSS THE SOUTH."
SO TO ME, IT’S A BALANCED
REPORT.
THAT’S WHAT IF YOU BEAUTY
METEOROLOGIST AND DATA PEOPLE
DO.
THEY JUST PUT THE DATA OUT AS IT
EXISTS.
I WAS SURPRISED BY THE PEACE
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE WILL TELL
YOU THAT I ERR ON THE OTHER
SIDE, TOO FORCEFUL AND TO DIRECT
ABOUT THE DATA AND WHAT IT’S
SHOWING.
I’VE NEVER ACTUALLY BEEN CALLED
AN OPTIMIST IN THAT WAY BEFORE.
>> Bret: THE LAST THING,
ANOTHER REPORT ON
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
DR. BIRX AND OTHERS FRUSTRATED
WITH THE CDC’S ANTIQUATED SYSTEM
OF TRACKING VIRUS DATA WHICH
THEY WORRIED WAS INFLATING
COUNTS.
THERE IS NOTHING FROM THE CDC I
CAN TRUST, DR. BIRX SAID.
IS THAT TRUE AND WHERE DO YOU
THINK THE CDC DATA IS TODAY?
>> THOSE ARE TWO PIECES PUT
TOGETHER.
WHAT ARE WE USING EVERY DAY?
THEIR SURVEILLANCE DATA, THE
EPIDEMIOLOGIC DATA, THE
LABORATORY DATA AND THE
INTEGRATION OF ALL OF IT AND THE
ANALYSTS THAT PROVIDE THE
REPORTS.
I RELY ON THOSE.
THAT DATA IS SUPERB.
THAT COMMENT WAS ABOUT DAILY
HOSPITALIZATION DATA WHEN WE ARE
FIRST TRYING TO PART PUT OUT
REMDESIVIR.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO ME THAT THERE
IS EQUITY AND HOW WE DISTRIBUTE
MEDICATION WHEN IT’S NEEDED FOR
A VERY SPECIFIC PATIENT.
WE WERE HAVING A REALLY
PASSIONATE AND COMPASSIONATE
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT’S BEST FOR
PATIENTS, AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE HOSPITAL DATA AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF DAILY COMPLETE
REPORTING.
THAT’S WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT IS THE HOSPITAL DATA
SPECIFICALLY.
THE EPIDEMIOLOGY DATA, THE
SURVEILLANCE DATA, THE INFLUENCE
ARE LIKE ILLNESS SURVEILLANCE
DATA, EMERGENCY ROOMS, ALL
TERRIFIC CRITICAL AND IT’S NOT
JUST THE DATA.
IT’S THE PEOPLE THAT THEY BRING
TO THE TABLE TO ANALYZE IT.
>> Bret: DR. BIRX, WE KEPT YOU
TOO LONG.
PLEASE TELL THE WHITE HOUSE WE
APOLOGIZE BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR